[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good day.
I'm Dean Marchiori.
I'm a statistician
from Sydney, Australia.
And I'm interested in
reproducible analysis
and workflow choices in R.
But in my day-to-day practice
in industry as a
commercial data scientist,
is my work actually
reproducible?
To answer this, I
conducted a reproducibility
retrospective or Repro-Retro.
I went back through the last
year of my commercial data
science projects and
rated at each project
across a number of dimensions
that are valued in my practice.
You can pick aspects that suit
your work but the dimensions I
picked cover if an analysis were
replicable, modular, auditable,
automated and collaborative.
So what were the results?
Out of 55 projects, I scored
an average of 3.8 out of 5.
This is good, but not great.
So if I care so
much about this, why
wasn't my work rated higher?
Here are the lessons I
took from my Repro-Retro.
Controversial opinion
number 1-- not everything
needs to be reproducible,
while all projects benefited
from some aspect of
reproducibility, the most
important consideration for
me was "How do you tell, what
needs to be reproducible?"
Enter my Fiji test.
So if you have a task that
sufficiently important,
you may want to
consider the Fiji test.
Aussies like Fiji because
it's only a few hours away.
But if you're lying on a
beach in holidays in Fiji just
spare a thought for your
colleagues back in the office.
If they need to rerun
some of your analysis,
will they be able to find
it, understand your work,
run it without too much fuss
and make reasonable enhancements
or small changes.
The last thing you want while
you're sipping a piña colada
is to be disturbed by a weird
phone call about some model
that you trained.
When I looked at the type of
analytics task I completed,
not everything needed
to pass the Fiji test.
A lot of work in industry
is ad hoc and quite simple.
In a commercial or a high
pressure environment,
I think it's
perfectly reasonable
to have different standards
on workflow choices
depending on the type
of work and the return
on investment that you need.
So long as a reasonable standard
is maintained and as long as
your team is consistent
with these choices.
However, this may
mean getting better
at anticipating the full
scope of the project
before rushing into
solving a problem, which
can be a challenge.
In addition, it
gives you the freedom
to pick a more lightweight
and flexible workflow
choice if desired.
My next lesson was picking
the right tools for the job.
You know, I've been searching
for the biggest and best
workflow choice but I found
it paid to have options.
When I examined my tooling
in workflow options,
the results of my
Repro-Retro varied.
Using a basic directory
structure template
to organize my projects
was OK around it.
Quickly got cumbersome.
Notebooks like R Markdown
were nicely replicable
but tended to be a bit of
a dumping ground for code.
Drake, a more formal
workflow system
carried a bit more
overhead and more
admin to get used to
but overall it enforced
much better standards,
particularly around writing
functional and modular code.
While any system can be made
arbitrarily sophisticated
and do a good job,
I found it more
effective to have a
few different workflow
choices available rather
than try a one size fits
all approach.
All workflow choices
are naturally
optimized for
certain applications
and I found it
better to only take
on additional complexity,
when the job really needed it.
Next I found in my work, I had a
tendency to mistake replication
for reproduction and the
same goes for automation.
Getting your code to rerun
is only part of the solution.
So consider the factors
that matter in your practice
and be deliberate about
what you optimize for
and use that to guide
your workflow choice.
And how do you do that?
Well, do a Repro-Retro.
The process wasn't
and isn't intended
to be scientific or unbiased.
The true value of a Repro-Retro
is in the self-reflection
and improvement.
So go and dig
through your old code
and think about how you
might do things better.
If you want to learn more,
you can reach out to me
or visit my analysis
flow GitHub repo.
I would also like to acknowledge
and thank my collaborator Miles
McBain for many interesting
discussions in this space.
Thank you and good luck.
[MUSIC PLAYING]